i'm looking at the vffs and i see a
bunch of women in there and some
wonderful gentlemen
as well and that's right guys and in the
mood board
of life which i do call this show i try
to make it a mood board
i'm going to switch gears and talk about
something very personal to me
uh several months ago i found myself
looking to change
how i reacted to my daughter when
she would i would try to get her to do
something and she would say something
really
hurtful back and um
it gutted me and i wanted to
stop the cycle break the cycle if you
will and
i thought what can we say to ourselves
to combat that hurt like redirect
de-escalate
get into the solve in a meaningful and
healthy way so of course i turned to
expert parenting um psychologist and
friend of the show dr elisa pressman
and one of her videos that's actually on
our website
was an aha moment for me
and uh so we thought we would talk about
this on the show
uh elisa are you there i'm here hi
hello how are you
doing well um okay
let's get right into it um of course i
want to sidebar and be like how's it
going
um why do so many people struggle
with the communication when things get
really tense
and feel straight-up mean with your own
children
well no one likes to be told
nasty things so no matter what when
someone says something
like i hate you and they're not your
child it's
terrifying you know it just sends you
into a tailspin but when it's someone
that you're raising you start to take it
really
personally in a different kind of way
because what happens is our brains go
into
i'm under attack so you go into that
the alarm bells go off i'm being chased
by a bear
like that's a primitive feeling and so
and automatically when you feel under
attack your body goes into
fight flight or freeze that's how we
respond and so we want to
attack back or we just shut down
or we run away yes exactly
right that's exactly how to keep that
down
okay so our response does it affect
the situation yes because if you think
you're being
attacked and you go into your stress
brain your attack you know the bear is
chasing me brain all of the resources
that you have
to think clearly have to go into i've
got to get away from the bear
and that's what's happening so you can't
be the kind of parent that's
showing your kid how to self-regulate
because you don't have capacity
to get yourself to self-regulate so
they borrow our kind of emotions and
they
borrow our responses so if we come at
them
when they're coming at us it becomes a
fight
if when they go into their threat state
which is what's basically happening if
they're
if like olive doesn't hate you her
feelings are so big that that's what
comes out of her mouth
she's just sending a message so we have
to think what is the message
what's the emotion under the behavior
that's our job
and our other job is to show our kids
that no matter
what we can handle their big feelings
we might not like their behavior but
their feelings are totally acceptable
i mean when i saw this video of yours
that talked about
how to stop yourself and sort of
get out of that fight flight freeze
because that is
it's like a knife going through your
heart when you hear your children
saying that you wonder if it's true you
wonder if you failed as a parent raising
them a certain way
it's so big and catastrophic and what
our talks did
was i just
stopped making it such a big deal i
started
changing my own reactions which did
de-escalate
the situation when i would walk out
dejected
my child knew olive knew that she had
the upper hand
she was accomplishing exactly what she
wanted to
and i didn't feel good nothing was being
accomplished and when i started changing
my reactions now when she says i hate
you i'm like
yeah okay and i actually feel that way
but it took me a while there was a
transition period
but it's like that don miguel ruiz book
the four agreements don't take it
personally
which is such a powerful thing hard to
practice but very very very
crucial i mean you in ch
it's like we as parents think what do we
need to do to our kids for
our kids in that moment and for me you
helped me
empower myself to realize that my
reaction
is going to start the ball rolling and
you talked about how it actually in that
moment
shows them how to cope handle
a situation as well you're not only
de-escalating
but you're imprinting good behavior
and you're imprinting self-regulation
like what you
said you know we spend so much time
focused on
will my like what can i do to make it so
that my child doesn't do this anymore or
behaves better but what you're teaching
them in that moment is
when someone is attacking you when
something goes wrong when someone's
having a difficult feeling
i take care of myself first so right now
i'm putting my hand on my heart and you
know you take a deep breath
because that regulates you it and if you
all do that now like you just can't help
it
you give yourself a little bit of a hug
and feel a little calmer to respond
so that when your children watch that
they now know oh
there's a point i don't i'm not there
yet but there's a point when
someone does something that upsets me
i don't have to go into attack mode i
can think about what do i want to
accomplish here
hey sometimes you might want to attack
back there may be a time when that's
appropriate
but you don't do it because you weren't
thinking clearly you take a breath
and then you decide and then you're in
control of your own
emotions and that's what our kids are
learning by watching us
yeah you're not going straight to hurt
you're you're
you're you're imprinting good behavior
taking that deep breath has changed so
much for me
and my chemistry and you have really
helped me break
a year's long cycle where the
child dynamic was completely off and it
is on track right now and
i cannot thank you enough please check
out this video
as well as others on our website that dr
aliza takes us through
the steps of parenting there are no
manuals but there are people out there
like elisa who can truly
reboot us and redirect us
in a very very helpful amazing way
i i'm telling you my life is the proof
of it so
i've really turned things around by
talking to people smarter than me
about these things so thank you dr elisa
i love you
[Music]
you